we're in a strange pocket of time where
we don't know how films films haven't
yet and there's no a comprehensive way
of delivering films digitally to
everyone ie all films on demand quickly
easily cheaply movie theaters don't have
digital projection yet which means
there's financial constraints for
certain films that right now are doing
well but because of the economics
doesn't make sense to make prints for
other theaters it's just better to show
them on demand in the theater and DVD as
a day in date situation which means
everything you know you can see it in
different forms all on the same day
which is what I've see in HD net and
other companies are doing more which may
be the future looks like the future so
right now people aren't can't quite
figure out how to make money on the
small films you know there's the fear
that the products being devalued and
people don't feel like they have to pay
for films the way they have for music
over the last few years so that's going
to be very difficult to you know will
that change will people I think the only
way it will change is if they figure out
that technology immediately you know and
and all the companies agreeing on a
single way to deliver the films by
broadband to people's TVs so that kind
of stuff is making it there's probably a
third the number of the films being made
as small films in our all films in there
were two years ago and they tend towards
the Giant you know 3d kind of thing
genre thing Hollywood thing or the other
side which is small films packed with
stars uh in a low-budget less than 10
million
and there's also this opportunity for
very cheap films to lead the way perhaps
in quality but also in economically it's
like how they're delivered so films made
for less than half a million you'll see
a lot more of you'll see them over 100
million and less than a half a million
and not as much in in the middle stars
seem to be less important for what
people want to see now than they used to
be they don't guarantee grosses anymore
which I think in a way is probably a
relief but it's confusing for the
studios people are aren't sure where to
put their money um and unfortunately it
takes time for good filmmakers to
develop there's not too many whose first
film is fully developed because you need
so many skills Musical actor financial
visual you know it's not just like
writing a song you can have people who
are you know prodigies it musically but
in a way you have to have prodigies up
people who can do all kinds of things in
order to be a good director so the first
film isn't always the best once in a
while you'll have someone very unusual
will come out like Jonathan couette
whodat our nation or you know Tarantino
when he you know reservoir dogs or
someone who seems to have mastered it on
their first go and those are very is a
rare but it's good you know David
Lynch's of the world and in Scorsese and
such made a lot of shorts and made some
early films that were finding their way
before they made their taxi driver or
their um you know blue velvet so it's a
it's easier to make films now tech
technologically financially you know the
equipment is there for young people to
do it there is the internet for
distribution about how do you how do you
make money while you're doing it
is the is the piece of the puzzle that
still to be figured out